migrations. It was the first,
which was a very small band
no more than thirty, less than
30 companions that migrated to
Habasha, Ethiopia first. that
time referred to as Abyssinia.
Then there was a second
migration as well which this
migration had more
participants. roughly 83 or
so historians differ slightly
but about 83 or so companions
that migrated there again. And
this is known as the second
migration. Then we the third
and final migration which was
not just a migration for those
who were in Mecca. This was a
generalized migration for
anyone who accepts Islam that
they migrate from their land to
the prophet in Medina. So,
migration was first permitted.
And then it was commanded if a
person had the ability from
Mecca to Abbasinia and then a
third migration which was
general. Anyone who became
Muslim, anyone who accepted
Islam. wherever they may be, in
the world, were encouraged, and
commanded if possible to
migrate to the prophet in
Medina. So, this migration took
place for a very specific
reason. That reason was to
escape persecution and
persecution is not just bodily
harm. It was not just because
their wealth was being
infringed upon and their bodily
harm and so forth. It was also
because their rights and we're
speaking about their religious
rights or their civil rights
because of their religion. The
rights were being infringed
upon and they were being
prohibited these rights. So,
what is the difference between
those two?
religious rights were being
impeded. Meaning that if a
person wanted to pray, he could
not pray publicly, he could not
pray with with any kind of
comfort. He could not pray in
the open. He could not allow
anyone to know that he was
praying. There would be
repercussions for this.
Likewise, there are certain
things expression of
Islam, Islam, an expression of
the rights of Islam, an
expression of the obligations
and prohibitions and the
superiority of Islam. This is
all part of that. Meaning that
not only is a person to be
permitted to practice Islam but
also permitted permitted to
promote Islam with a level of
autonomy. And to publicly be
Muslim. And and to publicly be
able to speak about the
beliefs
of Islam. This is a
major part.
and so, those rights were being
impeded, right? Those rights
were being impeded. Or a
person's civil rights were
being impeded because they were
Muslim. Meaning that they
weren't being directly
persecuted because they were
Muslim and those rights of
Islam were being prohibited.
But if a person was Muslim, he
is going to be harmed because
of his Islam and his rights are
going to be in turn less than
those of the rest of the
citizenry or the rest of the
tribesmen. and so, the prophet
was commanded to migrate to
Medina and as long as a person
was not in a land, that
prohibited Islam. Or had this
element of persecution, a
person cannot practice his
religion there freely. unless
that was the case, a person did
not have to migrate We have
examples of that. So, what do
we mean by that? So, when the
prophet was commanded to
migrate from Mecca to Medina.
That migration was because in
Mecca, it was unbearable
anymore. Beyond reason two, be
a Muslim at that point. It was
too cumbersome. to practice
your religion with any kind of
stability. and so, the command
was issued to anyone residing
in Mecca that was Muslim and
had the ability to to migrate
to Madina. Now, what about
people in other parts, people
in Yemen, people in Southern
Arabia, people in Hashem,
people in Iraq, etcetera where
Islam had spread to. Did they
have to migrate to Medina? This
is a difference of a in amongst
the scholars opinion of the
majority is that as long as a
person was able to practice his
religion openly and express his
religion openly without
persecution then they could
remain where they were but it
was better for them to migrate
to Medina, right? There's a
difference. So, we have a group
of people who are not
considered companions but
they're they're considered
because that's the only other
option but they were actually
contemporaries of the prophet
the only issue is is that they
did not meet him in his
lifetime as Muslims. So, these
folks are referred to as Al
Muhad Ramin. Al Muha had
different reasons for not
meeting the prophet some of
them were unable to, some of
them accepted Islam and and did
not migrate These some of them
met the prophet as non Muslims
and then later accepted Islam,
right? So, these
a lot of this happened because
and they are many. Because they
did not migrate to the prophet
because it was not obligatory
upon them to do so. This was
not obligatory upon them. To
migrate to the prophet and this
was one of the ways that Islam
was spread as well. Islam was
spread in this way that a
person accepts Islam. Then they
return to their tribe. They
return to their village. They
return to wherever they're
from. And they stay there and
practice Islam and their tribes
folk would become Muslim
etcetera. So many people
especially in the ninth year
after Hijrah. Many many people
began to travel to the prophet
remember, a lot of people could
not reach the prophet before
that, even though they had
heard of Islam and accepted
Islam, they couldn't reach him
because Quraish was actively
stopping people from arriving
at the prophet city. And so,
they would
They were abusing people and
they were stopping actively
restraining
people and
repercussing people for trying
to reach Medina. Now, the Mecca
happened in the seventh year or
8th year, difference of opinion
amongst the scholars. In
Ramadan, after that, everyone
was able to reach him with
relative ease.
and so,
we have this
this
year, it's referred to by
historians as the year of the
visits and that is that people
would come to visit the prophet
spend a week or two or a couple
of months as long as they could
and then return to wherever
they were and they would reside
there And so, it was not
obligatory upon them to migrate
to Medina but they were
encouraged to migrate to Medina
And so these are the different
stages that went through. These
are the different stages that
Hijla went to. It was allowed
and it was encouraged and then
it was obligatory. Given those
conditions that we've just
mentioned. We left off last
week discussing that first
Hijalah. said that that first
hijra was about 16 people. had
about twelve men and four
women. One of which was the
prophet
And that was Rukaya. They
migrated to Abbasinia and due
to a break in communication.
They returned unwittingly to
Mecca.
then a second a second
migration took place
and we mentioned that who's a
huge name in the companions of
the prophet he's one of the
seven most prolific narrators
of Hadith is one of the
participants in the battle of
and all of the battles and he
was Muslim in Mecca and Medina
and he's one of the foremost
scholars of all of the
companions
So,
Ibn Masauud was in Mecca.
He made that first journey to
Habasheh. He returned and he
entered Mecca and remained
there until the the major
Hijla. The Hijjla to Medina.
And so he did not go in the
second Hijla to Abbas and he
remained there with the prophet
and he made Hijra to Madinah
and there he was in the battle
of Badr and all major battles
after that until the death of
the prophet
He says,
[Silence]
and so,
The prophet allowed a second
hijra to Abbasinia. The prophet
allowed them a second trip and
there were more people in this
trip than the first.
and this time, things were not
so easy. We we remember the
converging of events which
allowed a swift escape for
those 16 companions in the
first Hijla. You know, they
left at a certain time. They
reached the water almost as if
it were planned. They were able
to find these ships. They were
able to make a swift escape.
This second time, it was not
the was not the case. The
second time was much more
difficult. They were pursued.
They were persecuted and even
when they reached to Abyssinia,
Quresh still sent a delegation
there to try to get them
essentially deported to
essentially get them driven out
by a Najeshi and handed back
over to Qureish.
[Silence]
In
others who were known to have
been participants in the battle
of Badr are mentioned amongst
those who made this second
hijra but there's a a bit of an
issue with that. And that is
that those who made this second
Hijra. Did not come back to
Madinah until after the seventh
year. After Hijalah. So if I'm
an earth were in the battle of
Badr. That was in the second
year after Hijrah. So how were
they in the battle of Badel and
part of that second group of
migrants at the same time.
there's one of two explanations
for that. Either Some other
things happened that weren't
recorded with regards to their
whereabouts. Meaning that they
came back later without coming
back with the rest and the bulk
of them. Stayed in Mecca for a
while and then came back to
Medina. That's one possibility.
Or those of the historians that
mention Amah and Earthman and
others them who were known
positively to have participants
in the battle of Badr. Now, you
know, Arthman wasn't at the
battle of Badr but he was there
legislatively.
Haba Sahu, Maradul, Zaojihi,
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
participants of Buddha. The
participants of Badr are the
most virtuous amongst all the
companions. with regards to
general virtue of the Muhajirin
and Ansar. So, if we were to
say, who are the most virtuous
companions? Well, we start with
Abu Bakr and then Omar, that's
agreed upon. And then, Earth
Men, in the opinion of the
majority, and then Ali, and
then the rest of the ten, the
ten companions who were ear
tagged for paradise and a very
dis narration. It's a narration
of Ibn Abbas, a narration of
Zaid that or Saad Ibn Za that
10 people are going to
paradise. This is how the
narration goes.
10 people are going to
paradise. And then he went on
to name them. Abu Bakr Al He
named ten. Those ten and that
narration, those are considered
the
are the most virtuous after the
four right? And then after
that, we would say, who is the
most virtuous after that? Those
who are most virtuous after
that are the people of Buddha.
Those who were were in the
battle of Badr, from the
Muhajirin and the Ansar. Those
are most virtuous. Those 300
some, 12, 13, 14. It's a
difference of opinion. Those
individual have a specific
place amongst the companions.
Because the prophet said,
Allah
that the prophet said regarding
the people who were in the
battle of Badr, do as you wish,
for I have forgiven you. So,
these people that were in Badr
are generally all considered to
be Muva Sharim Bil Jannah,
right? After that merit of and
the battle of is different than
any other battle. Because it
was most pure with regards to
those who are in the Muslim
side of that battle. Every
single person that fought in
that battle from amongst the
Muslims was a known believer.
There was not a single
hypocrite amongst them, right?
Later, later, battles, there
were always some hypocrites
there, right? And actually, the
battle of Badr is what really
sparked the phenomenon of
hypocrisy because after the
battle of Badr, when that
happened and so many of the
leaders of Quraish were were
killed and so many were taken
prisoner etcetera. So, there
were 70 prisoners of war in
that battle When that happened
you know, things started to the
the dynamic in the Arab
Peninsula became very different
now because the Muslims at this
point were were feared, right?
That we have to make sure we
stay away from in in impeding
and and doing all of these
harmful things to them because
the Muslims are now starting to
have military power and so now,
rather than just a Motley crew
of some people who ran away
from Mecca, now they were
considered a state, right? So,
when that happened, many people
enter this into Islam, not
because they became Muslim,
they entered into Islam because
they saw that the Muslim state
was now becoming very powerful.
It was starting to pick up
steam. They were starting to
become feared and were
acknowledged amongst other
regions and amongst other
tribes and so forth and so they
became Muslim to spare
themselves or they became
Muslim to gain whatever the
Muslims gains were, right? So,
every sequential battle after
the battle of Badr was a battle
that had some hypocrites
amongst them. But the battle of
Badr, there were Literally no
incentives to go to the battle
of Badr except forgiveness from
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
except for being with the
prophet that was the only
incentive They were not
promised any spoils of war The
battle of Badr. We're not
permitted yet. They weren't
prohibited but they weren't
permitted. So, there was no
spoils of war to be had in
going to the battle of Buddha.
Second of all, there was no
there was no idea of prisoners
of war that had been thought
about. that point because
prisoners of war when a person
is taken as a prisoner of war,
their family would send their
ransom and they would be
released, right? So, that's
good for the Muslims. It's good
for the state but that hadn't
been something that was
legislated
by Allah yet there
were no worldly gains as an
incentive for the battle of
Badr. Every one of those
companions that went
accompanied the prophet did so
merely out of the spirit of
being with him and standing
with him wherever he stood. And
so every one of the companions
that were in the battle of are
considered to be pu pure
Muslim believers paradise was
promised to everyone of them.
after the battle of Buddha,
hypocrisy started to find its
way into some of the ranks of
the Muslims. Hypocrites started
to join. People had different
reasons for joining. Some
people just to fight. and
they wanted to go to battle and
do these fantastic things so
that poetry would be written
about them and they could honor
their forefathers and so forth.
Some people went because it was
a good incentive for spoils of
war. If you go to war and and
we win, we get to gain from
that worldly gain. There were a
number of reasons why people
joined that were not Muslim who
joined this army. However, the
battle of Badr was did not have
any of that. It was purely a
battle of mere faith against an
oppressor.
Then, after the battle of Badr,
after those companions that
were in the battle of Badr, we
would say
the next most virtuous are the
people who made Bea under that
tree in Hadabia. It was about a
thousand, right?
that thousand give or take who
gave pledged allegiance to the
prophet under that tree in
Hudabia. They are most virtuous
in that order. Then, after
that, generally speaking, we
say the and then the right? So,
the order goes, Abu Bakr, Omar,
Arthman, and the opinion a
majority. Ali. And then the
rest of the ten that were
mentioned in that hadith And
then the people of and then the
people of Hadebia. And then the
Mohajirin and then the Ansar et
cetera. So we know that earth
man was considered amongst the
people of Badr. That is
something that there's no
doubt. It's beyond beyond any
reasonable doubt. That was
considered to be from the
people of he wasn't physically
there. Because the prophet
daughter, his wife was ill and
Arthman wanted but he was
unable because he stayed back
to take care of the prophet's
daughter. So, when the spoils
of war were taken and had for
the Muslims, he gave Arthman a
portion as if he was there. So,
physically, he wasn't there but
legislatively, he was and so
he's considered a badri. Also,
was part of and actually, that
allegiance that happen and
Hadabia was because of
earthmen. They sent him as a
delegate to Mecca before the
Muslims arrival to Mecca in
order to delegate that hey
we've come for Hajj. And we
wish to enter Al Masjid al
Haram and was sent as a
delegate for that. And he took
a little bit longer than they
expected to come back. And so
they feared that he was either
killed or he was taken taken as
a prisoner. And that is
absolutely against the laws and
rules of war. A messenger a a
messenger, a delegate, is never
to be dealt with with with
violence, right? and so,
immediately, if you, if you
send a delegation or you send a
messenger, and that messenger
is harmed, killed, or held
prisoner, that is an act of
war. right? That is an act of
war. That means that once that
happen, immediately, all
communication breaks down after
that. And this, this happened
even with even with the
messengers of,
Museilama. We know that there
were a few people who who laid
claim to prophethood in the
prophet lifetime before his
death and one of those was
Musai Lama. You know, he's to.
notorious as
he actually came
visited the prophet met him
the year of in the ninth year.
And then as he left, he
decided, hey, you know, this
prophet business is actually
pretty pretty good. I think I
might be a prophet myself. So,
after meeting the prophet he
went back to where he was from
Emmama and he claimed that he
was a prophet now, right? And
so, he sent some messengers to
the prophet to try to be
recognized as an as a prophet
as well. Look, I'm a prophet as
well and if we consolidate our
power, we can take over the
whole world together. Right?
And in Sahih Al Bukhari, the
prophet said to his messengers,
if messengers had it not been
for the the fact that
messengers are not to be
harmed, I would have harmed
you. I would you you would have
been brought to justice from
now, right? But because they
were sent as messengers, the
prophet allowed them safe
passage. So, if somebody is
sent as a messenger or
delegation or delegates and
they are harmed, they're
killed, they're put in prison.
This is an act of war. Right?
and so, in Hodabia when they
sent Arthman, he took a long
time to give back a lot more
than they had estimated for his
time and they thought that was
perhaps killed and so, at that
point, they were in a very
vulnerable position. Because
they didn't come for war. They
didn't have the instruments of
war with them, right? They just
had some spears, some arrows
for hunting, right? Just some
just very few things. They had
no artillery because they
didn't come for war. They came
for for Umrah and so, they
decided that if this happened
to Earthman and if it is to be
war, then let it be and so, the
prophet invited those who were
with him to pledge allegiance
and about a thousand of the
companions as he stood under
that tree, pledged allegiance
to the prophet to protect him
and to fight till death. Death
or victory. And so that Bea is
referred to as it's referred to
as the pleasurable allegiance
because Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala mentions in that Allah
is pleased with those who
pledged allegiance to you under
the tree. Right? So, it's
referred to as they are most
virtuous after the companions
of Badel. and then after that,
we have the Mohajirien in a
general sense, the Ansar in a
general sense and so forth. And
so, Earth Man is without a
doubt was in the battle of
Buddha. He's considered to be a
Badri and so how was earth man
in Ethiopia, Abyssinia, and in
the battle of Badr at the same
time. Either his name was put
into that group by accident
because remember, he made the
first hijra, the very first
Hijra. It's very easy to
confuse those two hijalas. Very
easy to confuse those two
migrations and perhaps some of
the historians confused some of
the participants in the first
as being part in the taking
part in the second. That's
possible. Or something else
happened with the likes of Amar
and the likes of earthmen. They
either came back to Mecca and
then from Mecca made Hijla
again or they broke off and
came to Medina. It's it's
unclear what had happened.
Ibn he tells us that the number
of men that made that second
hijra
were eighty-3, 8-3 men. If we
count Amar to be one of them.
If not, then eighty-two. And 14
or excuse me, 19 women were
considered and mentioned to
have made that migration a
second time to Abbasinia.
He then mentions a statement of
Ibn Saad.
that those companions resided
there in Abbasinia. One of two
things happened either they
stayed there until the seventh
year after Hijalah, after the
conquest of Mecca, and then
they made Hijra to Madinah, or
some of them broke off, and
when they heard the prophet
migrated to Medina, they wanted
to join him. And so, they left
to join the prophet so they
came in two waves. They came
back in two waves. A first
group and then a second, after
the Muslim state had become
very strong and permanent. This
is when they made that hijra to
the prophet it's mentioned that
some of them made their way
back to Mecca. And the numbers
differ on who they were and how
as as to who they were and how
many there were. However, what
we do know is that after the
seventh year,
We do know that after the
seventh year, when they
returned back to the prophet in
Medina,
that he sent a message or a
letter to a Najeshi. A Najeshi
is not his name, right?
Nejeshi is just the word
Firaun. It's just the term
that's used for the person who
is is considered the king in
Abbasinia. There's many in the
Jeshes, right? just like
there's many Pharaohs, there's
many and this is just a title.
This is not his actual name. As
for what his name was exactly,
it's a difference of opinion
amongst the scholars but what
we do know is that the prophet
sent a message to him asking
him to marry to him
And inviting him to Islam. He
did accept Islam. And he died a
Muslim and he is the only
person in the history of the
prophet time, era, that it
was made for that he prayed
from Medina. Which we will get
into that next week, a little
bit more details about Najeshi.
This is enough for tonight.
[Arabic recitation]